mais c'est un hôpital un peu spécial un
hôpital qui ouvre une fois par an où les
patients sont des peluches sabrina
accompagne son nounours petit ours brun
qui a la grippe
première étape consultation avec un
docteur pour le diagnostic chez dans la
salle des consultations et donc on
s'occupe d'accueillir les enfants avec
leurs nounous oms et de leur demander
le problème qu'ils ont le prénom de leur
noce leur prénom à eux aussi et on met
un peu en marche le début des soins
prise de température prescription de
médicaments petit ours brun aura même
droit à un carnet de santé une carte
vitale avant de passer en salle de soins
maintenant le ciel docteur qu'est ce
qu'on va faire alors vu qu'il arrive
désormais en huitièmes il a un peu chose
rare les causes qu'on va faire on va les
mettre une compresse poil sabrina pourra
même participer aux soins de sunu l'ours
comme un premier contact avec le monde
des blouses blanches aujourd'hui gasquet
l'a la grille pain ainsi qu'elle est
l'un des krachs qu'est ce que c'est mais
d'autres l'oratoire et bâle ont opéré
ici tout est prévu bloc opératoire
dentiste ou radiographie aujourd'hui ce
sont 110 enfants de grande section de
maternelle qui auront amené leur
nounours pour une première
sensibilisation qui profite à tout le
monde c'est surtout un peu une première
sensibilisation parce qu'en quatrième
année on a un stage obligatoire de
pédiatrie donc on se retrouve confronté
aux enfants auxquels on n'a pas
forcément l'habitude ba2
de se comporter avec eux et du coup le
ppte lé nounours c'est un peu une
première approche pour nous pour
s'habituer on en rappelle des la
consultation les présents que ça se
soigne très bien est la fin du parcours
on leur rappelle que le nom s'est soigné
dans la salle d'attenté on revient les
voir pour vérifier que nous reçoit bien
soigné leur rappeler et on retourne même
dans les classes deux semaines plus tard
pour leur rappeler leurs noms se soigner
aujourd'hui c'est une trentaine
d'étudiants en médecine de seconde année
qui ont opéré toute la journée dans un
hôpital chaque patient au sort guéri